i'm talking about hooters waitresses
right now oh when's the last time you
ate at hooters oh man it's been a while
easy maybe two or three years wings went
down actually no i went do you go for
the wings or the atmosphere i go for the
wings
yeah horrible decision go for the
atmosphere no what atmosphere it's like
so hooters waitress reveals basically
how much he makes in tips each week and
the amount will surprise you so here's
here's a story right here there's a lady
named kristen songer she kind of went
viral on tick tock you haven't seen it
she was basically explaining how much
hooters waitress makes uh talking about
the different options as far as outfits
that they have to wear because they were
basically considering going to a
skimpier little outfit i think they
reeled it back and they're going to keep
the traditional outfit because i think
that's going to be enough anyway she's a
south carolina grad usc maybe your
outfit
but i think they defeat that yeah maybe
i'll get she's attending medical school
but she was a hooters waitress right
and basically she broke down how much
money she makes as a hooters waitress
and i thought it was pretty interesting
number one if you're a server you
understand that uh you probably make two
bucks an hour on average but the real
money that you make is in the tips so on
average she said she can make on the low
end
50 bucks on a shift to a high end about
400 bucks wow okay so when you add that
up depending on how many shifts you work
in total she makes about 1300 a week in
tips now if you extrapolate that
and i'm not saying that she worked every
week or every month or every day of the
year whatever but you can be a 70k
earner
making that kind of money being a
hooters waitress putting yourself
through college making 70 g's not bad
not bad yeah it makes you maybe want to
get some fake
you know become a waitress i don't even
need a fake one
[Laughter]
i always think that the if i'm gonna be
a like a a fry guy or a busboy
or any sort of like staff help staff
yeah
go do it at hooters
just like if you're cleaning tables are
you a hooters guy or a twin peaks guy
uh i just found out about twin peaks
recently i'll get out of here so there's
no twin peaks in south florida that i'm
aware of or definitely hooters in miami
there's a twin peaks in west palm beach
i'll tell you what
i'm down to find out
okay okay
but basically
all right there's two parts of the story
here there's the the surface level part
of this how much do hooter waitresses
make you know 70 grand compare that with
the median salary you know and which is
40 50 grand in america right now who
does wagers are winning cool respect so
now you know a little all right cool i
get what is but the bigger thing is this
you know what i did in college
i was a server i was a waiter at hooters
not at hooters
at a wing joint in florida state
tallahassee shout out to john's fsu
johnson
johnson's
big richards that's big richard swinging
ds
um but there's certain things that you
learn as a server as a server and shout
out to my people who worked in the
service industry they understand yeah
that when you're a server
it's not just bringing out the food and
taking the order it's customer service
it's understanding how to interact with
all sorts of customers how to talk how
to sell how to upsell today we've got a
special that's going on right here how
to basically work for tips how to work
for commissions and many instances i
always say this
servers
actually make great sales people and
speaking of sales people this is how i
made my money being a salesperson in the
financial industry if you're not going
to be you know the traditional money
making careers doctors lawyers engineers
you got to be selling something go into
sales you got to be whether that's
financial services whether that's
medical devices whether that's real
estate well i have a buddy who's a
dildo salesman uh yeah pardon no
pardon this guy sells all the dildos out
there makes a killing who companies call
johnson's johnson
but he does but the point is that he
understands how to sell so
if you want to learn like people say
what's a great job to have in college
what's a well you know where can i start
learning about you know i say look if
you want to be an intern like at a
career that you want to be in yeah you
know double down on that if you know
that you want to be an accountant go get
a internship at a cpa firm cool i got
you but if you want a good career path
that you know will translate into the
working world go be a server
i'm telling you serving is a great way
yeah to
learn sales and learn interacting and
you know what it is
even when you don't want to be there
even when you hate the customer because
they're rude
hi welcome to hooter like you still got
to put on a smiley face yeah that's
sales so i had a conversation the other
day where it's like would you rather be
a hundred percent authentic this is what
dinkin would rather be a hundred percent
100 authentic
but it jeopardized business
opportunities and pissed people off
maybe okay or kind of have to
tell you know white lies or not be true
to yourself
but make more money what would you pick
the latter i would say it's not even
close yeah it's not even close yeah
absolutely it's business
is what they call in spanish yeah i'm
not here to make friends i'm here to do
deals i'm not encouraging you to lie
and and and cheat and steal that's not
what i'm saying you're encouraged to win
like uh yes get that deal i'm not gonna
just be completely transparent and tell
you yeah yeah last night i went out i
got freaking wasted bro i don't think
you unders i'm not gonna tell that to
business people no why that you know so
he's talking about being authentic
versus you know being successful
what what would you prefer so my point
is this if you're if you're a server
sometimes you might have to show up and
put on a smiley face
even though you're having a shitty day
that's business is the special any good
it's the best thing i've ever tasted
the sirloin oh my god at johnson's yeah
at johnson's today their special is the
hot dog
anyway that's my two cents right there
servers make great sales people if
you're looking for a career like i i
definitely i don't want to on
servers out there
you know because i know that there's
people who work for like joe stonecraft
which is like the most iconic restaurant
in miami again we're in south florida
here they make maybe six figures a year
maybe from what i hear yeah so that's a
career path for them but for the most
part
get in and get out of the service
industry yeah get in and get out mario
mario did a video on valuetainment uh
entrepreneur series about perspective
and about
making your everyday your work day yeah
some people want to don't you i don't
want to go into work man i hate being a
servant
it's all about changing your perspective
you do change it to like okay i need to
make these many sales because this will
help me in x you know i'll make this
it'll make work less because that's the
thing that's the pushback by being a
server like it's not going anywhere i'm
not gonna it's just a server job i hate
it here yeah it's all about perspective
you change that like you said it's
training for something bigger to be this
great sales person i don't know i've
lived by this thing that like i could be
doing whatever it is but i want to be
really good at it like i was a bank
teller for a little bit and i don't want
to be a bank teller obviously you know
me that's not in my but i was doing it
for college and i was like okay well i'm
gonna try and be the best bank taylor
here
and i
i wasn't
no but i i tried okay and that's the
thing you just have to try and give
yourself a purpose i like that david
thank you respect to you david i think
your young david's doing great by 100th
episode 100 episode david's gonna be a
billionaire we all know that anyway so
if you're a server out there shout out
to you
and remember tip your server ladies and
gentlemen these people are working on
tips yeah there's nothing worse than
working your ass off being a server
people treating people the right way
delivering the food yeah and then you
get a shitty tip i always tip 20 if they
do great it'll be maybe a little bit
more very rarely am i doing less than 20
tip your waitress all right so shout out
to the hooters waitresses out there and
call david if you're looking for a good
time
all we talk is money if you enjoyed that
short clip from the sauce cast click
here to watch another click here to
watch the full episode or just stay
broken